[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde Ukraine Israël les nouvelles
guerres de civilisation l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie a commencé le 24
février 2022 elle se solde par des
centaines de milliers de morts de part
et d'autres et si la résistance
ukrainienne a stoppé les envahisseurs la
guerre dure encore et place l'Europe en
difficulté
stratégique la tentative d'invasion
d'Israël par le Hamas le 7 octobre 2023
a provoqué le pire pogromeme connu par
l'État hébreu de depuis la Choa une
guerre s'en est suivie et se poursuit
avec ses morts et ses destructions quoi
de commun entre ces deux conflits fort
éloignés géographiquement mais qui
s'apparentent par de nombreuses
similitudes géopolitique socio-culturel
militaire stratégique et qui témoignent
d'un désordre mondial sans précédent
relevant d'affrontement de civilisation
pourquoi ce sont des guerres de civ
mais tout simplement parce qu'elle
s'exerce sur le temps long de l'histoire
elle m en jeu des passions de foule
exacerbé par des nationalismes ambiants
font plus que des dégâts collatéraux par
leur possibl extension régional qui en
Europe qui au Moyen-Orient voire mondial
mais aussi parce que les guerres
ukraine- Russie et Israël Gaza
s'inscrivent en matière de soutien et de
AG des grandes nations dans la dualité
politique des rapports de force mondiaux
avec en ligne de mire un affaiblissement
de l'Occident et un regroupement très
hétéroclite de régimes autoritaires
nommés Grand Sud global Parton pour en
parler je vous présente mes invités
Édouard guilla vous êtes amiral ancien
chef d'état-major des armées de 2010 à
2014 Philippe Gelli vous êtes
journaliste rédacteur en chef du service
étranger au journal Le Figaro Galia
Akerman vous êtes historienne
journaliste et esséiste Claude moniqu
que nous avons en
visionférence vous êtes analyste
géopolitique directeur de l'Européan
stratéique intelligence and security
Center pardon pour l'accent Jérôme Gedge
vous êtes député Parti
socialiste
[Musique]
vous venez de voir cette citation de
volodimir
Zelenski l'impérialisme russe
anciennement soviétique et auparavant
tariste a toujours vocation à des
extensions
territoriales après avoir annexé la
Crimée en 2014 le donbas poursuivre et
plus encore aujourd'hui est-ce à dire
que la Russie est mal à l'aise dans un
territoire bordé de frontières et
cherchera toujours à s'agrandir Galia
Akerman c'est un peu
inscrit si vous voulez dans la matrice
de l'Empire russe qui avait vocation
affichée par plusieurs tars de
s'agrandir je crois que c'était
Catherine 2 qui disait que le l'État
russe pour se défendre doit
nécessairement s'élargir et c'est
surtout le 19e siècle qui a connu des
élargissements spectaculaire sur l'Asie
centrale l'Extrême
Orient aussi les les frontières
occidentales de la
Russie donc il y a rien de nouveau là
sauf qu'en
199091 il s'est retraéc voilà voà il
s'est retraé à plusieurs reprises il
faut le savoir parce que déjà après la
révolution de 1917 euh Lénine n'a pas
réussi à conserver tous les territoires
de l'Empire russe et donc il y a eu
toujours des grillefes vis-à-vis de la
Pologne et des pays baltes et de la
Finlande en particulier maintenant en
91 le l'Union soviétique se décompose
Ilin accepte l'idée des frontières
existante et puis quand Poutine arrive
au pouvoir les idées Revanchistes font
euh peu à peu leur ch et maintenant on
parle même de façon encore informel de
la reconquête d'Alaska sans parler de
l'ukraineci merci Galia Philippe géier
est-ce que c'est le propre de
l'impérialisme que d'élargir ses
frontières parce que aujourd'hui on
connaît des pays qui n'ont pas de
frontières mais il y a énormément de
contestations frontalières est-ce que
tous tous tous ces pays ont une tendance
impérialiste
euh impérialisme et expansionisme se
vont souvent de pè en effet mais euh la
question que ça pose à mon sens c'est
celle de de ce qu'on met en face
c'est-à-dire que la Russie euh a je
pense euh comme le dit
Galia ces espèces de gêne un peu
expansionniste mais aussi cette culture
de mettre tous les Russes sous le même
chapeau sous le même parapluie partout
où il y a des Russes c'est la Russie bon
il n'y a pas non plus des Russes dans le
monde entier donc il a un moment
Vladimir Poutine en campagne électorale
a déclaré récemment et d'ailleurs c'est
ça figure sur des affiches à Moscou les
frontières de la Russie ne s'arrêtent
nulle
part pour nous ça ça paraît un peu
vertigineux mais je pense que c'est une
figure rhthorique assez banale dans la
dans la dans la psychologie politique
russe et toute la question est de savoir
si en face il y a a des Européens forts
un une autant forte des américains
présents capable de dire au Russe là
pour vous c'est la ligne que nous
traçons et que vous ne pouvez pas
dépasser alors bien sûr il y a le cas de
l'Ukraine où là la ligne a été dépassée
ouais alors d'un point de vue militaire
qu'est-ce que vous en dites
amiral c'est c'est assez compliqué on on
a d'ailleurs des parallèles à faire
entre ce qui se passe à Gaza d'un côté
on va l'aborderprès ce qui se passe en
Ukraine ce que ces deux conflits nous
montrent euh et et c'est là où on on
arrive ensuite aux civilisations qui
soutendent les états ce que ces deux
conf nous montrent c'est d'abord que la
paix n'est pas définitivement acquise on
se souvient de l'affaire des dividendes
de la paix et que c'est un combat
permanent ce que le monde occidental
avait totalement oublié c'est le réveil
est assez est assez brutal la deuxième
chose que ça nous montre c'est que la
technologie ne remplace pas tout l'art
de la guerre n'a pas fondamentalement
changé les outils qu'on utilise sont
différents si la technologie remplaçait
tout les Ukrainiens qui ont bénéficié de
la technologie occidentale auraient
remporté plus de victoire donc le
facteur humain reste absolument prignant
et le Hamas aurait été détecté avant et
là on voit bien que cela ça devient une
affaire de renseignement mais c'est
encore le facteur humain alors quelque
part c'est rassurant de se dire que
l'homme reste au centre de la boucle
mais là aussi c'est quelque chose que
que nous avions oublié et donc à partir
à partir de là
oui on peut basculer sur les sur les
civilisations mais la civilisation russe
fondamentalement elle est pas si
différente de la civilisation ouest
européenne par contre très différente de
la chinoise de l'indienne voire même
elle est plus différente de ce qu'il y a
en Amérique du Sud s c qu'il faut
regarder ou du militaire je voudrais
bien sûr vous laisser répondre sur la
question des frontière mais en
l'abordant à travers les deux conflits
si on prend le conflit
israëlo-palestinien on sait bien qu'il
est parsemé de crise et de guerre et il
y a jamais eu d'accord territorial
malgré la décision de l'ONU en 48
d'attribuer à la fois Israël au
Palestiniens malgré les accords d'Oslo
l'une des revendications phare
palestiniennes telle qu'elle s'est
exprimée à après le 7 octobre c'était
from the river to the sea de la rivière
du Jourdain à la Méditerranée en somme
un État palestinien qui effacerait de
facto
Israël
revendication reprise tout récemment par
Khaled méchal l'un des dirigeants les
plus importants du
Hamas de sur croix cet impérialisme là
se nourrit d'un un ingrédient religieux
qui s'appelle la OMA ou communauté
islamique comment sortir à votre avis de
cet absolutisme territorial ben d'abord
en rappelant c'est le point commun aux
deux conflits la question des frontières
dont on pouvait
penser qu'elle n'était peut-être plus
aussi centrale dans les relations
internationales qu'une forme de
stabilisation des frontières pouvait
résulter vous savez moi j'appartiens à
cette génération qui avait 20 ans au
moment de la chute du Mur de de de
Berlin où on nous expliquait euh que la
fin de la guerre froide allait permettre
la fin de
l'histoire le la victoire de la
démocratie libérale du modèle de
l'économie de marché bon c'est tout le
contraire qui s'est passé euh et donc on
a vu ressurgir comme jamais euh la
contestation des frontières à travers le
monde on parle de ces deux endroits
parce que ça a été euh en tous les cas
en tous les cas l'atteinte à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine par la Russie
euh eu égar les deux protagonistes et
notamment l'un d'entre eux membres du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
c'est-à-dire garant de la Charte euh de
l'ONU qui elle-même euh euh garantit les
frontières c'estàdire que là on était
dans la contradiction absolue euh de ce
nouvel ordre mondial l'expression est
plus utilisée on l'utilisait beaucoup
euh beaucoup il y a 20 an donc cette
question des frontières et et euh et et
et le fait d'en invoquer du coup le
droit international est absolument
crucial dans le cas Israël Israël Gaza
je pense qu'il faut quand même apporter
un
petit un petit bémol from the river to
the sea c'està-dire la destruction
l'État d'Israël c'est la
revendication du projet
théocratique porté par le
Hamas le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est que le reste de l'expression
politique palestinienne qui devrait et
pourrait passer par l'autorité enne est
totalement démonétisée décrédibilisé
inaudible la question des
frontières pour aller droit au but
là-bas elle passe à un moment donné une
fois qu'on a dit évidemment que
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas est un
supportable condamnable le pogrom vous
l'avez vous l'avez rappelé mais elle
remet
elle rend inévitable la question des
frontières d'un État palestinien et de
la reconnaissance d'un État palestinien
et donc d'une sit d'une solution
politique et je veux aussi ajouter un
point parce que c'est une question qui
se pose vu le choix de du thème de de
débat que vous avez retenu est-ce que
dans les deux cas on est vraiment dans
des guerres de civilisation moi je suis
très méfiant je vous parlais des du
Nouvel Ordre Mondial la fin des années
début des années 90 je pense à Samuel
witington on nous théorisait le choc des
civilisations on a l'intention d'en
parler j'imagine mais parce que en
filigrane il y a quand même cette idée
aussi qui a pu être utilisée par
certains que c'est le combat du Bien
contre le Mal et si on est dans le
combat du bien contre le mal alors on
peut plus faire de géopolitique on peut
faire de relations internationales et on
a un surplomb moral terrible qui
rend inatteignable la complexité des
relations internationales ça je récluse
un peu le terme oui alors Jérôme G on va
en parler parce que là on avait décliné
un point commun c'est la question des
frontières mais Philippe Gell est-ce
qu'il y a pas un autre point commun en
la question de la démographie parce que
si on prend les deux conflits on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a des déplacements de
population si on prend l'Ukraine on on
pense qu'il y a 100 millions de de
d'ukrainien déplacés depuis la guerre
pour des raisons à cause de la guerre et
si on prend le conflit à Gaza vous avez
la population du Nord et du sud d'Israël
qui est aujourd'hui déplacé et vous avez
les déplacement de population à Gaza
donc cette comment vous appréhendez
cette question de la guerre oui l'effet
de la guerre oui vous avez parlé
d'impérialisme tout à l'heure
impérialisme russe vous avez laissé
entendre qu'il y avait un impérialisme
du Hamas ça me fait penser qu'il y a
vraiment un impérialisme du puissant et
du faible parce que l'impérialisme du
Hamas ne ne remet pas en cause à
supposer qu'on puissealif se sert de la
démographie non je veux dire la la les
déplacements de population sont le
résultat des bombardements massifs sur
des zones habité par des civils dans les
deux cas le problème qu'on a en
l'occurrence c'est que que et si conflit
de civilisation il y a du moins si on
nous le reproche c'est parce que dans un
cas on juge que c'est parfaitement
inacceptable que la Russie envahisse
l'Ukraine et bombarde les populations
civiles du donbas et dans l'autre cas on
un certain nombre de de décideurs
occidentaux juge justifier que les
représailles du Hamas contre le le les
crimes du Hamas se soit opéré de la
manière dont elles le sont par Israël
qui a la main qui a la puissance
militaire en l'occurrence euh je ne dis
pas que le Hamas est inoffensif loin de
là mais la supériorité militaire est
quand même clairement du côté d'Israël
donc ce que vous disiez sur
l'impérialisme du Hamas on peut aussi le
retourner et poser la question de
l'impérialisme israélien puisqu'il y a
aussi des extrémistes en Israël qui
disent la même chose Israël du Jourdain
à la mer donc là je ne mets pas sur un
parallèle absolu les deux situations
mais effectivement le leur cause sont
différentes leurs ressorts sont
différents après dans leur les
manifestations qu'entraînent la guerre
il y a beaucoup de points communs ouais
alors Claude bque sur la question à la
fois des frontières de la démographie et
du lien entre les deux conflits
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors sur
le lien entre les deux conflits surtout
je pense que ce qui fait la force de de
la Russie aujourd'hui c'est notre
faiblesse c'est le fait que après la fin
de la guerre froide l'Europe s'est
gentiment assoupie dans le beau
magnifique rêve du soft power en pensant
qu'on pouvait tout régler par la
diplomatie par le commerce international
par le libre échange et par l'extension
de la démocratie on voit bien
aujourd'hui avec ce Sud global au que
nous faisz allusion que le modèle
démographique ne séduit pas tout le
monde que certains États qui ne sont pas
démocratiques comme comme la Chine comme
l'Inde dont le côté démocratique peut
être discuté ne fonctionne pas si mal
que ça et donc peuvent représenter
peuvent attirer une partie de une partie
de l'opinion mondiale on a oublié que en
définitive et c'est vrai malheureusement
ce le son l'histoire on est au 21e
siècle on est dans une période qui
devrait être
assagie l'histoire reste ce qu'elle est
et dans l'histoire les conflits se
règlent le plus souvent malheureusement
par la guerre et par la violence c'est
une réalité que nous avons oublié nous
nous sommes désarmés nous avons envoyé
des signaux de faiblesse et on le voit
très bien aujourd'hui à la fois dans
notre réponse à ce qui se passe en
Ukraine et dans la les divisions qui
peuvent exister dans le soutien que nous
apportons à Israël Claude boliqu juste à
votre avis une précision nous allons
aborder le cas de
l'Iran un peu plus avant dans l'émission
mais ce que vous avez dit concernant
l'Occident et la Russie affaiblissement
de l'Occident la Russie en a profité à
votre avis et sans développer plus
largement la la question est-ce que vous
pensez que l'Occident c'est montré
faible vis-à-vis de l'Iran et l'Iran en
a profité avec ce conflit du 7
octobre est-ce que vous faites un
parallèle entre les deux à ce niveau-là
je pense que malheureusement l'Europe
s'est montré l'Europe en tout cas s'est
montré faible par rapport à l'Iran
autour des questions des négociations
nucléaires où on a bien vu et je serai
très court on a bien vu et s prouvé par
le rapport de de l'agence atomique après
rapport deagence atomique depuis des
années depuis 20 ans l'Iran se moque du
monde l'Iran trompe les ins eur l'Iran
dissimule un programme qui a des
finalités militaires et nous continuons
en Europe à dire qu'il faut retourner à
la table pour discuter il y a un moment
je pense effectivement que je dis pas
que il faut bombarder l'Iran mais cette
idée effectivement chez les Iraniens a
clairement
entraîner la la conclusion que nous que
l'Europe était faible et que la seule
puissance sur laquelle il fallait
compter c'était les États-Unis oui
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez amiral
éouard guilla je suis je suis
complètement d'accord plus plutôt qu'une
guerre entre civilisations c'est une
guerre faite à ce que nous pourrions
appeler la civilisation occidentale et
pourquoi est-elle faite parce que les
hommestant étant ce qu'ils sont c'est
toujours la loi du plus fort qui va qui
va vouloir prévaloir qui va tenter de
prévaloir nous nous sommes montrés
globalement et collectivement assez
faible et bien ça donne effectivement le
conflit en Ukraine ça donne Gaza et ça
peut donner d'autres d'autres points de
friction dans le monde Galia
German je voudrais peut-être faire deux
remarques d'une part il y a souvent
confusion entre le problème palestinien
qui est un problème véritable et très
ancien déjà et le Hamas et les
revendications du Hamas qui veut tout
simplement la destruction d'Israël il
faut quand même rappeler que la
l'Autorité palestinienne au moins
officiellement ne veut pas de
destruction d'Israël et
reconnaî l'existence de l'État d'Israël
de même que plusieurs pays arabes Arab
pas tout pas tous bien sûr donc ce qui
ce qui se passe en cas de Hamas c'est
que une organisation terroriste reconnue
comme telle par les États-Unis l'Europe
s'est emparé d'un état et donc l'état
qui était installé à Gaza on peut le
comparer par exemple à daesh ou plus
anciennement à Al-Qaïda et il a é
toujours été reconnu par l'ensemble des
pays occidentaux comme légitime le euh
l'intention de détruire ces états
terroristes ce qui se passe actuellement
ce n'est pas une vengeance ce n'est pas
une réponse tout simplement à cette
attaque purement terroriste le
pogromme qui qui a eu lieu le le 7
octobre de l'année dernière c'est que
Israël a compris que tant que euh le
Hamas n'est pas éradiqué dans la bande
de Gaza euh il y a pas de cohabitation
possible maintenant on peut discuter
est-ce que toutes les mesures prises par
Israël sont justifié au non mais
essentiellement c'est c'est une
guerre contre une entité terroriste qui
prendent la destruction totale d'Israël
oui mais on va contextualiser ça Jérôme
g
donc d'une part c'est ça et ensuite
c'est vrai que voilà je je je réagis à
ce que vient d'être dit par l'amiral euh
que en effet les les deux conflits
n'étant pas pour moi conflit de entre
civilisations ou vous allez voir qu'on
va avancer dans ce domaine moi je
voudrais revenir sur cette question sur
cette
question
1991 la chute du communisme la chute du
mur de Berlin on a pensé on s'est trompé
qu'on pouvait démocratiser euh la Russie
euh la chute de l'État islamique on a
pensé que les pays arabo musulmans se
réconcilié avec la
démocratie les conflits sont toujours là
que ce soit en Syrie en Irak on voit
l'explosion du ramas et cetera à votre
avis
euh ça prouve que l'histoire est
irrationnel dans le cas on le voit et on
voit comment on s'est trompé par rapport
à cette histoire irrationnel et qui
produit des crises dans un peu partout
dans le monde le politique que vous êtes
ne se dit pas que finalement c'est une
défaite politique parce qu'il n'arrive
pas
et on n'arrive pas à influer sur la
conflictualisation du monde mais cela
renvoie ce que je disais tout à l'heure
moi je veux pas donner l'impression
d'avoir la nostalgie de la guerre froide
dans laquelle euh les deux figures
tutéire l'URSS et les États-Unis euh
s'assurer au moins des souverainetés
territoriales et des intégrités n'était
pas partie prenante elle-même je je
réinsiste sur ce point l'implication
directe de la Russie dans le conflit
avec l'Ukraine c'est une bascule
fondamentale on n plus dans des conflits
par euh allié ou par territoire
interposé en Afghanistan ou ou ailleurs
donc moi je veux pas avoir la nostalgie
de cette période là évidemment parce
qu'il fallait sortir de la menace
qu'elle pouvait représenter mais c'est
vrai qu'on a probablement pêché par
angélisme dans la S dans la chute du mur
de Berlin et d'ailleurs probablement
dans cette décennie qui aurait dû être
celle de la construction de ce nouvel
ordre mondial la décennie en gros entre
89 et
euh et et 2001 parce que à ce moment-là
on a une autre bascule qui est le 11
septembre 2001 avec la nature ayant
horreur du vide l'irruption cette
fois-ci de celle des revendications et
et c'est ça que je trouve intéressant
pardonnez-moi l'expression dans ce qui
se passe entre Israël et et Gaza
c'estàdire que là on a une revendication
de nature identitaire religieuse qui
s'impose et qui matrice la totalité des
relations des relations internationales
en disant cela je ne veux pas pour
autant je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure d'ailles le terme de guerre de
civilisation il y a toujours ce risque
n' pas n'ayez pas peur des mots vous
allez voir j'ai pas peur des mots mais
je dis juste que si on le fait euh le
risque c'est le conflit entre le bien et
le mal et l'assignation du bien à
l'Occident et du mal à ce Sud global
parce que c'est en philigram ce qui peut
transpirer alle VO on va en parler vous
allez voir mais alors Philippe Gelli on
a parlé de l'Iran l'Iran livre des
drones à la Russie ces drones ont
massacré la population ukrainienne
l'Iran arme le Hezbollah arme le Hamas
arme les
outil sincèrement à votre avis quel ce
que veut l'Iran et qu'est-ce que peut
l'Iran dans ce conflit et dans ces deux
conflits si on prend le cas de l'Iran à
mon sens il s'inscrit assez bien dans
votre thématique parce que si conflit de
civilisation il y a euh je pense qu'il
il se joue entre le le l'ouest et le
reste euh je crois plus à l'ouest global
qu'au sud global qui est en fait
beaucoup plus hétéroclite que l'Ouest
global et dans l'Ouest global il y a
effectivement aussi Israël et ce ne sont
pas des concepts géographiques et en
face de l'Ouest global qu'est-ce qu'il y
a il y a des puissances dont dont la
force s'exprime essentiellement par leur
capacité nuisance je mets dans cette
catégorie la Russie qui est une
puissance à la hauteur de sa capacité nu
ance et on voit qu'elle est grande et
l'Iran il en va de même
euh et donc dans leur à mon sens je je
suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que l'Ouest
global dont on parle paye sa naïveté ou
sa faiblesse il paye aussi sa domination
du monde pendant des décennies après la
deuxème guerre mondiale on a imposé un
système un ordre international qui avait
beaucoup de vertus mais dont on n pas
toujours respecté nous-mêmes les règles
quand les États-Unis ont envah dire ou
quand Israël ne respecte pas les
résolutions de l'ONU euh et il y en a eu
des dizaines qui lui demandaient de
respecter les territoires conquis après
67 et donc aujourd'hui on paye d'une
certaine manière la facture je dis pas
que c'est bien fait pour nous hein pas
du tout mais on est face à ces
puissances qui ont une grande capacité
nuisance et c'est le cas de l'Iran qui
active tous ses relais d'ailleurs
probablement en collusion plus ou moins
étroite avec la Russie on voit bien que
ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient avantage
enfin convient est une espèce d'auben
pour pour Poutine dans sa guerre en
Ukraine et alors à une époque George de
bibouche parlait de l'axe du mal
Benjamin netanahou a repris cette
expression ces derniers temps euh on va
pas rentrer dans cette rhétorique là
mais on voit bien que si affrontement
civilisationnel entre guillemets il y a
pour moi il est entre ces deux groupes
de forces pour autant je je je je pense
qu'une guerre de civilisation c'est
c'est par exemple entre les empires
austro-hongrois et et Ottomans là oui on
pouvait parler de guerre de civilisation
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt une une guerre
pour reprendre sa place ou rééquilibrer
les les équilibres mondiaux Galia Carman
vous avez est-ce que vous pouvez dire ce
que vous pensez de ce rôle de trait
d'union de
l'Iran je pense que l'Iran a ses propres
intérêt pour Israël il a proclamé
officiellement le désir de de détruire
Israël c'est son objectif prononcé donc
il est tout à fait normal qu'il soutient
tous les mouvements terroristes que vous
avez déjà énuméré euh quant à la Russie
c'est un partenariat stratégique d'une
autre nature l'Iran n'a aucun intérêt
particulier en Ukraine euh mais il est
partenaire de la Russie qui développe
son énergie nucléaire euh et qu' ils ont
beaucoup de projets de coopération il y
a aussi cette idée en effet dont
Philippe a parlé de d'affaiblir voire de
détruire l'Occident ça c'est une
revendication
idéologique qui n'est pas en soi
strictement
civilisationnelle pour nous parce que
quand on parle d'un conflit de
civilisation il faut il faut que les les
les deux parties soient en conflit nous
on n'est pas en conflit avec euh mais
vous n'ayez pas peur n'ayez pas peur des
mots vous AZ voilà mais mais euh mais
euh la Russie par exemple a ouvertement
proclamé ça fait partie de sa doctrine
maintenant qu'il faut détruire
l'Occident qu'il y a une civilisation
occidentale il y a une civilisation
russe qui est faux à propos euh parce
que la la la civilisation russe
historiquement fait partie comme ça a
été déjà signalé ici de l'Ukraine mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est que
il y a il y a
la comment dirais-je le combat affiché
contre l'Occident par la Russie pour
l'Iran pour des raisons aussi
idéologiques religieuse il est important
de combattre également l'influence
occidentale vous entendu g je voudrais
poursuivre sur cette question avec vous
Édouard Guillaum
l'Iran aujourd'hui
a obtenu une victoire avec le 7 octobre
la la fin l'impossibilité d'établir des
relations entre Israël et l'Arabie
Saoudite qui auraiit concrétisé une
apothéose des accords d'Abraham noué par
Trump à votre avis si Trump est
réélu est-ce que quelque chose peut
changer dans ce domaine parce qu'on sait
qu'elle était sa position vis-à-vis de
l'Iran
je pense qu'il va falloir que tous nous
relisions l'un de ces livres qui était
l'art de la négociation the art of the
deal Trump est un homme d'affaire qui a
toujours considéré que il fallait
négocier alors on l'a vu avec l'affaire
des des des accords d'Abraham et donc
oui ça ça une élection de Trump
rebattrait les cartes mais il y a une
chose qui ne va pas changer c'est que
l'Iran comme la Russie et Madame Akerman
vient de le rappeler a des buts de
guerre affiché ou le Hamas le Hamas
c'est la destruction d'Israël ça c'est
c'est bien connu quels sont les buts de
guerre du bloc occidental quand on
répond les buts de guerre et les
militaires ont toujours besoin de but de
guerre pour savoir ensuite comment
passer de la stratégie à générale à la
stratégie militaire et la stratégie
militaire à la tactique quels sont les
buts de guerre de l'Occident global les
valeurs aller expliquer ça à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas d'eau qui n'a pas
d'électricité ou ou qui a une histoire
multimillénaire mais qui n rien à voir
avec celle de
l'Europe nous nous n'avons pas encore
été capable nous occidentaux et le bloc
occidental est assez
largea j'aime bien l'idée de de West
global nous n'avons pas encore été
capable de déterminer queles étai nos
buts de guerre alors que d'une certaine
façon c'est nous qui sommes
agressés nous globalement oui Claude
Monique ve intervenir
oui sur l'Iran mon impression c'est que
le euh la Russie a un intérêt direct
face à l'Europe qui est effectivement de
de de nous écarter d'écarter l'Europe
surtout le temps de ses frontières et de
construire un espèce de glacer à partir
de d'anciens pays de pays qui
appartenaient anciennement au bloc à
l'Union soviétique comme l'Ukraine
peut-être demain la la Moldavie ou la
Géorgie euh la stratégie de l'Iran est
différente la stratégie de l'Iran est
dirigée essentiellement contre les pays
sunites du Gulf contre l'Arabie Saoudite
et contre les autres pays sunites et
contre Israël et quand l'Iran s'attaque
à l'Occident et l'Iran s'attaque à
l'Occident je vous rappelle que en
octobre 83 euh les Iraniens par hzbollah
interposé ont assassiné 200 soldats
américains et 68 soldats français à
Beyrouth je vous rappelle les attentats
du comis par l'Iran à Paris entre 2015
entre pardon entre 1986 et et et
1987 donc quand quand quand l'Iran nous
attaque c'est pour nous éloigner de la
scène moyenne orientale l'Iran voit bien
que nous sommes le enfin nous l'Ouest
global dont nous parlions les États-Unis
et une partie de l'Europe nous sommes
non seulement les soutiens d'Israël et
des amis d'Israël mais ou des alliés
mais nous sommes aussi des alliés du
monde arabe modéré de de du du monde
sunnite du Golfe et c'est pour ça que
les Iraniens veulent nous écarter par
tous les moyens de de cette région pour
se retrouver dans un espèce de Hu clos
où il y aurait eux les pays sunnites et
Israël leur but aussi par rapport au
pays sunites c'est de montrer via leur
soutien en Hamas qu'ils sont les seuls
aujourd'hui à réellement soutenir et je
mets des guillemets la cause
palestinienne donc c'est une stratégie à
tiroir qui est assez typiquement
iranienne mais qui peut fonctionner et
et qui fonctionne quand on voit qu'on a
sur la question du Hamas quand même
l'Iran qui soutient qui arme qui finance
une organisation qui est directement
issu des Frères musulmans qui sont ce
que le sunisme a de plus extrémiste
c'est quand même assez étonnant non
merci voulez dire un mot là-dessus
Jérôme non mais je je je pense que dans
les deux conflits puisqu'on cherche des
points de
convergence cette question des buts de
guerre est essentielle on elle est
clairement identifiée vous l'avez dit du
côté de la Russie c'est le but de guerre
c'est de se glisser dans ce qu'on
évoquait au début de l'entretien à
savoir de repousser les frontières de
l'Empire russe à forcuriie quand il a le
sentiment à tort ou à raison qu'il est
menacé ce qui pose aussi la question de
la manière dont nous concevons le rôle
aujourd'hui de de l'OTAN faut jamais
oublier c'est je dis pas ça pour trouver
des circonstances atténuantes évidemment
à la à la
Russie mais que la manière dont
changement de nature de l'OTAN en tous
les cas à travers l'extension jusqu'aux
frontières de la Russie de cette
alliance a pu encore une fois je le
pense à tort fournir en en tous les cas
a fourni le prétexte et donc c'était une
interprétation à tort pour la Russie
pour se glisser dans ces dans dans ces
buts là les buts du ramas ils sont ils
sont identifiés cassés le rapprochement
ça a été rappelé entre Israël et le
prolongement des accords des accords
d'Abraham et donc probablement même
casser la possibilité d'une réellement
d'une solution d'une solution à deux
états pour utiliser ce kiste palestinien
pardonnez-moi l'expression comme un
facteur de déstabilisation globale donc
nos adversaires
tous les cas voilà leur leur leurs buts
sont identifiés en réponse c'est là que
nous avons une grande difficulté du côté
israélien c'est le problème de Benjamin
netanahou aujourd'hui c'est quand on a
deux buts de guerre à ce point cont
enfin à un moment contradictoire libérer
tous les otages il faut pas oublier qu'
sont la prolongation de ce poogrom et en
même temps
dmilitariser éradiquer neutraliser le le
ramas les deux buts de guerre ne sont
pas ne sont pas atteignables à tel point
qu'on a le sentiment avec benamin
netanou aujourd'hui que le but de la
guerre la fin de la guerre si j'ose dire
c'est presque une guerre sans fin c'est
une guerre qui s'autoalimente
même je vous feris simplement remarquer
Jérôme Gates que l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux considèr que le ramas est un
groupement terroriste et qu'après le 7
octobre l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
a considéré qu'il fall all détruire le r
Oui mais sauf que qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire détruire le Ragas et quand vous
avez gagé dans dans le cabinet de guerre
israélien aujourd'hui qui dit nos buts
de guerre ne sont pas identifiés donc on
ne peut pas gagner la guerre quand il y
a pas de but on peut pas la gagner oui
mais je vous rappelle cette chose
[Musique]
là alors revenons à notre débat ces
conflits parmi d'autres conflits à haute
intensité ont des répercussions
mondiales qui ébranle l'économie les
sociétés accroissent le désordre mondial
nous sommes tous d'accord là-dessus mais
comment vous expliquz le soutien de
franches politiques dites progressiste
et du
voquisme une forme de convergence
d'ailleurs intersectionnelle entre le
voquisme et une gauche très progressiste
à un iréantisme islamopolitique et
symétriquement l'appui de très
nombreuses nations à la Russie Philippe
Gell ce débat ben oui parce qu'on est là
dans cette le général mais non ce que je
pense c'est que on est on est dans le
piège du double du du de poids de mesure
ce que les angl Saxon appellent le
double standard
dou c'est une accusation qui nous est
faite à laquelle on on peut très
difficilement
échapper parce que ceux qui vous disent
dans un cas vous considérez qu'il est
légitime de mener une guerre
euh très brutal de
bombardement y compris sur une ville
comme Gaza la ville de Gaza et cetera au
nom des représailles et de de l'objectif
juger légitime d'éradiquer le Hamas de
notre côté vous avez ptin qui tient un
discours exactement parallèle il dit
regarde en Ukraine il y a un régime nazi
nous on n'est pas d'accord et on on
estime que c'est de la propagande de bas
étage mais sur la scène mondiale c'est
perçu il y a une certaine équivalence
dans l'analyse que font euh qu'on peut
faire de ces deux discours et donc euh
euh il y a dans nos sociétés euh des des
courants que vous les appeliezquisme ou
autres qui qui considèent que nous
sommes piégés par ce par ce deux poid de
mesure que ce deux poids de mesure
existe on peut vouloir y échapper mais
c'est très difficile et que euh d'autre
part euh ce que nous défendons si N si
nos arguments sont valides pour dénoncer
l'invasion brutale et les crimes de
guerre commis par Poutine en Ukraine
nous devrions aussi dénoncer la
politique israélienne militariste et
bellliiciste d'un gouvernement qui ne
veut pas partager reconnaissez que les
soutiens
socioculturels sont identifiés d'un côté
comme de l'autre
euh oui enfin c'est pas c'est ce que
l'on observe c'est pas non plus une
exclusivité me semble-t-il de de de de
il y a des tas de gens qui se posent la
question de savoir comment soutenir
validement de
manière cohérente la résistance
ukrainienne quand quand un jeune
ukrainien tire un cocktail Molotof lance
un cocktail Molotof sur un char rus
c'est un héros quand quand un jeune
Palestinien fait la même chose sur un
char israélien c'est un terroriste cette
contradiction là je suis désolé mais
nous ne l'avons pas surmonté nous
globalement en tant que société
occidentale oui et si vous permettez
votre cartographie elle tient pas parce
que une partie je crois pas que
l'extrême droite européenne et française
notamment peut être identifié au wisme
que dont vous parliez à l'instant or les
sympathies à l'endroit du régime
poutinien elles viennent en France en
tous les cas de cette mouvance là
davantage que du wisme de la gauche
existe aussi à l'extrême gauche oui mais
l'extrême gauche n'est pas n'est pas la
gauche dans son ensemble ça vous a pas
échappé oui Galia guman moi je pense que
Philippe gulier a tort parce que on ne
peut pas absolument pas mettre sur le
même plan l'action militaire qui est
menée en Ukraine et celle qui est menée
dans la bande de Gaza pourquoi parce que
vous faites abstraction de qui est
l'agresseur et qui est l'agressé là dans
le cas de la Russie c'est la Russie qui
est agresseur donc on assiste à une
légitime défense dans le cas de du Hamas
et donc de pseudo état créé dans la
bande de Gaza c'est Hamas l'agresseur et
c'est l'action d'Israël qui en principe
est défensive même si on peut discuter
de tel ou tel épisode il faut pas
exprimer mon opinion personnelle j'ai
dit comment la lecture était faite voilà
on va le laisser exprimer son opinion
personnelle après c'est parce que c'est
parce que euh je je l'ai déjà dit au
début de cette émission on est on fait
une confusion monumentale entre la
Palestine les droits du peuple
palestinien et l'État terroriste créé
par le Hamas même si une grande partie
de l'opinion publique palestinienne en
désespoir de cause soutient l'action de
de Hamas c'est pas la même chose je
pense qu'il faut une fois pour toute
trancher entre alors j'ai vécu 5 ans à
Jérusalem et j'ai j'aiétais
correspondant dans cette région je ne
fais pas la
confusion bien sûr bien sûr en tout cas
on peut avoir des opinions qui sont
divergentes Claude bonique
oui je dois dire que ce qui m'a étonné j
j'ai raison de souligner dans l'extrême
gauche pas dans la gauche en général
puisqu'il y a des gens de gauche qui qui
soutiennent Israël même si on peut
critiquer par ailleurs certaines
méthodes utilisé par Israël et certains
excès de la guerre c'est un un débat
parallèle euh ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
surpris ou ou pas vraiment d'ailleurs
dans dans les positions deextrême gauche
c'est une espèce cette confusion entre
le défendre les civils palestiniens la
population palestinienne défendre
théoriquement l'autonomie la liberté de
la Palestine et défendre le Hamas ce
sont des choses qui sont non seulement
différentes mais contradictoire le Hamas
est sans doute le pire et dememi de la
cause palestinienne je veux dire il faut
être très clair là-dessus et en le
soutenant et quand on voit ces jeunes
qui défilent dans la rue en criant
effectivement de la rivière à la mer et
on a tous vu ce serait presque drôle
c'était pas triste que qu'ils ont du mal
à la mer il la situe à peu près quoi que
certains pensent que c'est la mer Rouge
mais mais le fleuve quand on leur dit
quel fleuve là c'est on a un peu perdu
c'est c'est triste ça montre qu'on a mal
expliqué les choses ça montre qu'il y a
eu énormément de propagande qui était
qui était qui visait non pas de nouveau
à défendre la Palestine ce qui est une
cause tout à fait juste moi depuis
toujours et quand je vivais en Israël
c'était déjà ma position je suis pour
une solution et une paix à deux états
c'est la seule qui soit raisonnable il y
a aucune garantie qu'elle apportera la
paix la seule garantie que nous avons
c'est que si on ne va pas vers cette
paix vers cette solution de états on
continuera à voir la guerre pour 1000
ans et c'est ça qu'il faut dire et il
faut dire que le Hamas est l'edemi de la
cause palestinienne et dénoncer le Hamas
qui est d'une organisation criminel
terroriste et quasiment génocidaire
Édouard guillaot oui il y a un autre
point je pense qu'on on confond un tout
petit peu le Hamas on l'assimile à la
bande de Gaza le Hamas existerait sans
la bande de Gaza le Hamas a fait son nid
dans un territoire mais le Hamas en
réalité on voit bien qu'il ne n'en a
rien à faire de perdre
pas Gaza lui il se reconstituera
ailleurs il migrera et ça restera une
organisation c'est sont les Frères
musulmans qui font penser liés aux
Frères musulmans issus des Frères
musulmans dont le but et la destruction
d'Israël d'une part et le but général
des Frères musulmans c'est d'avoir un
islam politique régant sur le maximum de
territoire de la planète d'autre part et
donc il faut bien séparer en plus à mon
avis la question de la bande de Gaza ce
qui amène la les problèmes de
destruction les victimes collatérales
tout ce qu'on veut et tout ce qui est
absolument épouvantable en opération
militaire en zone très urbanisé de
l'attaque et la volonté affichée et qui
me paraît normal d'ailleurs de vouloir
détruire le Hamas en tant que tel ce
sont deux aspects différents on a
tendance à dire si Israël prend tout
tout Gaza ou réoccupe tout Gaza comme il
l'a fait il y a quelques années il y a
plus de Hamas non non c'est pas vrai il
y aura toujours un Hamas il ira ailleurs
et d'ailleurs les autres États arabes
n'ont aucune envie de le voir arriver
chez eux ils le trouvent très bien à G
ilard Guillot vous pensez que la
vocation du monde arabe c'est de
secréter un extrémisme islamiste non pas
du tout ça non mais ce qui se passe pour
l'instant les les les États arabes et
musulmans arabes musulmans en général ne
soutiennent soutiennent assez peu et on
sait bien la cause palestinienne ça on
le voit depuis 30 40 ans et ne la
ressorte que quand ça leur apporte un
gain diplomatique ou un gain de
politique étrangère et pour l'opinion
internationale et finalement ça arrange
un peu tout le monde que d'accord il y a
un prurite qui s'est créé il est à Gaza
qui reste à Gaza ouz Claude moniqu
voulait intervenir al c'est c'est on
recnais que c'est horri je suis d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire l'adéral
guilla euh je pense qu'il y a un but de
guerre israélien qui est assez réaliste
c'est de dire on va détruire le ramas ce
qui ne veut pas dire grand-chose
l'offensive israélienne peut très
fortement affaiblir le Hamas une série
d'autres mesures qui sont légalement
discutables comme les les assassinats
ciblés qui vont se poursuivre entre
autres dans des pays où sont réfugiés
des dirigants du ramas peuvent également
affaiblir l'organisation mais en tant en
tant qu'idée elle va continuer à exister
et il s'incarnera d'une manière ou d'une
autre soit dans à nouveau dans le Hamas
soit dans un autre mouvement ça n'est
pas tant que le monde arabe a vocation à
sécréter le l'extrémisme il il y a des
courants extrêmement modérés dans le
monde arabe mais il y a et on ne peut
pas le nier dans le monde arabe en tout
cas certainement depuis 20 à 30 ans il y
a une tendance salafiste Frères
musulmans extrémiste qui est importante
qui qui est minoritaire mais importante
et qui continuera à s'exprimer donc le
ramasse ne sera pas totalement détruit
il sera pas éradiqué il sera affaibli et
au moment où il sera affaibli c'est là
je pense qu'il faut en profiter pour
faire avancer les négociations pour
faire avancer les possibilités de cette
paix ou de cette neutralisation du
conflit avec une négociation deux états
avant que le Hamas son successeur et la
possibilité merci Claude alors écoutez
je voudrais aborder la question que vous
avez souligné dès le départ Jérôme gagee
sur la question de pourquoi ces guerres
sont des guerres de
civilisation on doit à Samuel unticton
une prévision contestée sur le conflit
des
civilisations certains ont considéré que
c'était exact d'autres ont considéré que
c'était
erroné mais au regard des conflits
actuels on en a parlé depuis un moment
quoi penser de la prévision reprise par
de nombreux observateurs que les
conflits les plus étendus que nous
observons appartiennent à des culturelle
différent est-ce que vous êtes au moins
d'accord avec ça non je vous redis que
je récuse l'idée du choc des
civilisations on ne parle pas du choc
des civilisation conflit de civilisation
est-ce que aujourd'hui ces conflits
opposent des entités culturelles
différentes au regard de de la
polarisation du monde non le meilleur
contreexemple on l'a évoqué dès le début
je considère pas que l'Ukraine et la
Russie participent d'identité culturelle
diff voilà c'est d'ailleurs ça qui est
terrible c'est que nous avons un conflit
sur le sol européen entre Européens avec
des spécificités et des histoires
particulières mais l'Ukraine vous est
plus proche que la Russie culturellement
oui ou non ah très sincèrement jusque-
là aujourd'hui l'Ukraine m'éproche quand
elle dit mon avenir aujourd'hui face à
la menace que représente la Russie mon
avenir c'est de demander l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne ça verra le jour dans
15 ans dans 20 ans d'entretemps moi je
suis un Européen qui crois en effet que
les espaces de coopération sont ceux qui
permettent précisément de sortir
rappelez-vous enfin pendant des années
des années on a considéré qu'il y avait
une identité Bose et une identité
française qui était absolument
incompatible et qu'on a réussi à les
mettre dans un creusé commun qui était
celui de la construction européenne
voilà donc oui je récuse les choc de
civilisation euh parce que derrière
parce que derrière je vois bien la
petite musique je le redis qui est celle
du camp du Bien et du Mal moi je sais
pas qui dé don ex écoute dans le bien ou
dans le mal laissez-moi Jérôme GCH que
chacun donne de mettre de de l'eau dans
à votre moulin regarde un des endroits
où où où il y a le plus grand l'un des
plus grands risques de guerre mondiale
c'est Taïwan est-ce que Taïwan entre
Taïwan et la Chine on doit parler de
conflit de civilisation oui mais
Philippe gé sincèrement je vous pose la
question à titre personnel vous êtes
plus proche de taiïwan culturellement ou
de la Chine culturellement mais c'est
une vraie question mais c'est une
question à laquelle il n'y a pas de
réponse si il y a une
réponse pour moi il n'y a pas de ce
n'est pas un conflit de civilisation
c'est un confl politique entre la
démocratie et le communisme la
démocratie de Taïwan étant soutenue par
les démocraties européennes et surtout
américaine et et le régime communiste
chinois s'aliant avec un régime
autoritaire en Russie oui mais est-ce
qu'il y a des affiliations culturelle
non pour moi c'est pas un conflit de
civilisation ce sont des chocs de
puissance des
sur ce
point depuis quelques années la Russie a
une idée qui a été empruntée à l'extrême
droite bon maintenant tout le régime est
extrême droite mais ça date encore de
quelques années quand le philosophe
Alexandre dougin que tout le monde
maintenant connaît a proclamé qu'en fait
il y a plusieurs grandes civilisations
dans le monde que la Russie est en état
de civilisation et que la civilisation
Occident dentale ne doit pas être
prépondérante elle doit être au même
titre que les autres civilisations et
que donc eux c'est une civilisation
occidentale perverse délé TER
impérialiste et cetera mais bon on va
les laisser dans leur dans leur fange
mais il faut que tout soit à l'égalité
ce qui veut dire aussi que chaque
cordonnier est maîre chez soi si la
civilisation chinoise traditionnellement
est autoritaire et ben c'est comme ça si
la civilisation russe ou ce qu'ils
appellent la civilisation russe est
contre LGBT et bien ainsi soit-il et
donc et donc ce ce qui se passe en
Ukraine c'est pas même oui on peut dire
que c'est un conflit entre civilisation
la pseudo civilisation russe et la
civilisation occidentale par le corps de
l'Ukraine interposé ça c'est leur
interprétation qu'il combatt l'Occident
en la
personne on a très peu de temps on a
très peu de temps je voudrais avoir
aussi deux autres avis et je crois qu'on
vous a entendu voulez conclure votre
propos
et oui ce que ce que ce que je veux dire
c'est que le propos russe est encore
plus pernicieux il considère que
l'Ukraine n'a pas né ni civilisation ni
état ni culture propre que c'est une
sorte de variation avec la Russie qu'il
faut la détacher de l'Occident conquérir
même en en somm effacé l'Ukraine ils
l'ont déjà dit alors Édouard guillaot
sur ce point là pas de guerre froide
mais on constate une polarisation du
monde qu'est-ce que vous en pensez on on
constate une polarisation avec un une
dimension que le à mon avis nous n'avons
pas abordé qui la dimension
religieuse Moscou se voit comme la
nouvelle Rome et je je vais paraphraser
Poutine tout ce qui est orthodoxe est
russe c'est-à-dire que la moitié des
Balcans est russe par exemple h la
religion bien c'est le le marxisme le
l'éninisme chinois leur ser leur sert de
religion les on a parlé de l'Iran tout à
l'heure et bien c'est le chiisme et puis
les Frères musulmans pour je parle pas
des des pays mais les Frères musulmans
c'est une c'est une forme de sunisme et
ceci soutend à chaque fois la
civilisation vous avez une religion ou
l'équivalent d'une religion plus une
histoire commune plus des aspects
culturels commun vous merci d'avoir
apporté Claude boniquet il nous reste
moins d'une minute sur ce point et sur
ce cette polarisation du monde alors je
crois que la polarisation effectivement
n'est pas entre civilisation et culture
elle est entre modèle politique d'un
côté vous avez une partie du monde qui
croit qui malheureusement est assez
restreinte aujourd'hui qui croit à la
démocratie et qui croit au droit
international et de l'autre vous avez
des gens qui n'y croient pas je pense
que le problème il est là et je pense
que le le deuxième problème c'est que
nous l'Occident global comme vous disiez
dis tout à l'heure on a on n pas on n'
pas été toujours à la hauteur de nos
idéaux à la hauteur de ce que nous
devrions être et effectivement ça a
entraîné la désinfection d'une partie de
gens qui sont pas les acteurs principaux
du Sud global mais qui sont les suiveurs
qui aujourd'hui vont se retrouver
derrière la Russie la Chine ou d'autres
pays parce qu'ils pensent que ce sont
eux qui sont plus à même de les défendre
contre nous qui ne sommes pas la hauteur
de ce que nous sommes et qui ne et qui
pratiquont effectivement trop souvent le
deux poids de mesure merci Claude bique
alors écoutez il me reste peu de temps
si pour vous présenter quelques livres
qui traitent du sujet que nous avons
évoqué Bruno tertray la guerre des
mondes paru aux éditions de
l'Observatoire le retour de la
géopolitique et le choc des
empires je voudrais rappeler votre livre
Galia Akerman vous avez publié avec
Stéphane Courtois le Livre noir de
Vladimir
Poutine Claude moniqu je voudrais
rappeler que vous avez publié djihad et
islamisme en Belgique aux éditions
Jourdan Leclair en un mot mais pas
vraiment 20 secondes comment se porte le
djihadisme
d'ambiance à molenbec et dans toute la
Belgique il se porte aussi bien qu'à
roubet tourcoin ou que dans la Bonlieu
de Toulouse ou que dans celle de Londres
il y a un mouvement salafiste qui existe
qui continue à croître moins fortement
qu' a qu' a 5 ou 6 ans mais qui est
toujours là et dont une partie le
diadarmé mais c'est pas c'est pas mon
der pas plus de temps excusez-moi Claude
merci je vais terminer avec vous Jérôme
Gat vous avez été l'objet d'une Kabale
antisémite alors encore sur ce sujet-là
cette Kabale intervient au moment où les
actes antisémite sont très nombreux je
sais on va pas faire l'histoire de
l'antisémitisme il en est pas question
mais à votre avis quelle est la marque
de fabrique politique de l'antisémitisme
qui vous a visé il est universel ce que
j'ai reçu quand on me traite de de
je peux pas savoir si ça vient de
l'antisémitisme profond de l'histoire de
l'extrême droite en France je peux pas
savoir si ça vient de du nouvel
antisémitisme de l'islamisme radical par
contre il y a une chose et d'ailleurs on
le voit dans les conflits internationaux
à la fin du fin il reste toujours des
antisémites quel que soi les comp est-ce
que vous associez l'islam au gauchisme à
ça mais je je viens de vous le dire
c'est quelque chose qui est partagé par
tous ceux qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre mettent en question les piliers de
la République et parfois ça se croise et
ça se parle aux uns aux uns aux autres
voilà merci Madame merci messieur
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
à l'équipe de LCP qu'il l'a réalisé et
avant de nous quitter je vous laisse
avec cette pensée les puissances
occidentales n'ont pas de meilleurs
moyen de servir la paix du monde
rest drite et fermeouard gu c'est qui
ça comme on dit en français VO c'est le
général de
[Musique]
Gaulle